but we are better than men i agree that
gender does not exist
i don't follow everything andrew tate
says but i believe i live with men i
think we're better than men he has he
has had a an influence on today's
society are you a woman or pro math i
don't define a man and a woman so could
i be a man yeah people talk about men's
issues all the time shame insult guilt
need
how do you define born as a man humans
are so made for the camera to bring the
money for the females to go shopping i
don't bring this energy welcome welcome
to world star what up guys welcome to
the just pearly things youtube channel
today i'm in piccadilly square i'm gonna
be interviewing people on my sign which
is feminism is a supremacy movement
let's see what the people of london
think don't forget to like the video
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell
let's get started
okay so
feminism is a female supremacy movement
agree or disagree agree why because i'm
a female
i'm a female so of course i agree okay
do you think it's at the expense of men
like women want to be better than men no
no definitely not not better than men
but we are better than men why do you
think we're better than mine i just
think we are why i just think we are do
you think that's a bit sexist no you're
not so why i live with men i think we're
better than men i do i don't know i'm
just saying like how is that not sexist
like if men thought they were better
than women wouldn't that be sexist no
i'm not talking no i wouldn't think that
okay i'm just asking it's a personal
opinion okay yeah
okay but i think we're better than them
why do you think women complain about
double standards like for example
the pay gap right but they don't
complain about getting into bars for
free so it's crazy because these girls
like seem pleasant they'll seem nice and
everything but they'll say the wildest
[ __ ] like she's like yeah we're better
than men
what if men walked around and said we're
better than women i mean men can't even
say they're better than women at sports
and that's just empirically true that's
just true but like nice pleasant you
know like ladies can just walk around
saying we're better than men men are
trashed
and no one cares or free drinks at the
bar but i'd imagine if the rolls were
reversed and men were getting free
drinks and in the bar for free there
would be a problem i'm not gonna lie
i've never gone to a bar for free so
never a pretty girl i'm surprised
usually they'll let them in in the front
no and i've never got a drink for free
you've never had a man buy you a drink
never couch cat i swear i swear
never in your life you've never you've
never had a boyfriend oh yeah i've had a
boyfriend taking you on a date and paid
oh yeah but i've paid
oh so you you date bombs yeah basically
but no i've never had that okay what
about let's take finance let's take
abortion right that was a big thing in
the u.s right but we don't talk about
financial like a man is going to be
forced to be a father but a woman's not
forced to be a mother so why why don't
we ever talk about that because men
don't like talking about stuff like that
do they no i think they do it's just
they're made fun of
yeah when they talk about men's rights
they're made fun of do you think yeah
all the time women are you pro women or
pro math i'm i'm pro-equality like the
real form of it of course of course i
think if like men get to choose if women
get to choose not to be mothers men get
to should get to choose not to be father
yeah a hundred percent yeah but but
that's not the way the laws are set now
and we never talk about it but when roe
versus wade happened he got pregnant uh
would you ask the boy what he wanted to
do well i think i think he should be
able to sign off his rights and not pay
child support do you think he shouldn't
pay child support no he shouldn't if he
doesn't want to yeah if he doesn't want
it yeah they can they can go to jail in
the uk and in the us if they don't pay
child support they're stuck so it
incentivizes women to get kids off of
rich guys
so what i'm saying is like feminism says
they're for equality but if they were
they would talk about men's issues too
yeah people talk about men's issues all
the time okay okay i have kids with men
okay and the men don't pay for anything
and they've not been arrested
i'm saying but they legally can i don't
i don't know who you who you know
but i'm saying legally they can go to
court if they wanted to and they can go
to court but it doesn't mean anything
but i'm asking how is that fair but what
about if the girl loses
if the girl loses they don't they do no
they don't not statistically speaking
women women pay child women pay child
support like 15 of the time it's a very
small percentage it's not a very small
percentage i know a lot of boys that
have babies and don't pay anything they
don't pay anything okay i don't know who
you know but i'm going off of stats i'm
going off stats as well okay what stats
do you have a lot of mem friends okay
i'm talking about like actual data
actual data well i don't know where
you've come from
yeah but you can you can look it up it's
not you can just google it yeah i don't
agree men and women have equal rights at
the end of the day
yeah that's what i'm thinking it's all
men you can't truly
so today we're talking about the topic
feminism is a female supremacy movement
do you agree or disagree i agree with
you why i think women
very
they're very entitled today in terms
with preferences so a woman can talk
about preferences uh like she wants a
guy that's six foot two and he has to be
that high but if you ask a woman her
weight which she has control over yeah
honestly like
genetically speaking
feminism but i don't think it's a female
okay i think it's equality i think
feminism is equality okay we're i'm
going to finish interview with him and
i'd love to talk with you guys if you're
if you're free sorry so yeah so um men
uh have genetics and obviously these
genetics determine height yeah and but
woman you can exercise exercise is free
you have your body
legs
yeah exactly so they they make these
super
judgments
but when you judge them you're evil oh
you're cruel body shaming anytime men
have a standard they're ashamed for it
if they say i don't want to [ __ ] they're
shamed 100 yeah 100 like they want they
want to be superior in that sense to be
able to have their own preference but
when they're judged for
their weight they want to cry about it
when they want to sleep around and
someone calls them out for it uh they
don't like it i don't follow everything
andrew tate says but i believe he has he
has had a an influence on today's
society and i agree that um some of his
points do make sense i agree that if a
woman has a really high body count less
men would want her and yeah and i think
it's the same for men as well
you don't think so are are women worried
about drake's body count you go
appointment
are there are they
are they worried they're
materialistically developed if it's a
random guy with a body count of 60 you
know he's less like they're less
inclined to want him not not really a
random guy
it's not what feels really poor and he
had a high body count look at there are
poor guys that they get girls left and
right i don't know man like i know a lot
of girls really they want they want high
materialistic valued men it's just it
just
it's just the data doesn't support that
because if you look at dating app data
it's like five percent of the men get
all the swipes the reason that my women
think about our trash because they're
all [ __ ] the same statistically
speaking so i can't argue that yeah yeah
because it's not yeah come on
[Music]
this girl got so angry and it's just
some people i just don't even see the
point of arguing with or cause i don't
even want to argue i'm just trying to
have a conversation and they come at me
or a debate you know and they come at me
so heated and i'm just like lady take
your anger
elsewhere i don't need it here this is
this is the town of pleasant people
maybe not london no offense to you guys
but like this is this is the
the the fan base the subscriber base of
pleasant happy people
so yeah yeah i hope you work on that i
don't know i think it's all the same you
think first wave when they're asking
so i'm saying it's important to get you
in the shot so if you want to come in
the shop
so the reason i think it's a it's a
supremacy movement is because we're
asking for freedom without the
responsibility
even with the right to vote it was the
freedom to vote without the
responsibility of getting drafted the
responsibility of getting drunk yes
because if we go to war men get drafted
and then it's the same now as in we have
the responsibility to vote no you have
you asked you asked about first wave
feminism i asked which i asked which
wave you were talking about and you're
saying
i said yes because i think it's always
been the same movement it's always been
a hate group it's always been a
supremacy movement let's say you live
your whole life and your entire life
you're not allowed a job you're not
allowed a bank account you're not given
those rights let's say you get the right
to wrote woohoo we've got the right to
vote right and yet you okay we're not
being drafted right but the rest of your
life you're being deprived of all of
these roads you're gonna use one
argument of the draft to say that the
reason is because there has to be and
the right to the draft right i
understand okay let's put women into the
giraffe right sure do you want that sure
equally drafted frontline where
me you're you're talking about like so i
saw i'm saying saying we have we
understand what you're saying i need you
so you keep you keep you keep cutting me
off and it's quite rude cutting you off
because your your statements are so i
know the statements are so made for the
camera your statements are so made for
the camera to be i'm saying just because
just that they're going to get votes
cool get it
you're being rude for no reason like and
that's like girls think they get like
because you and how you talk because i'm
being very polite i'm not cutting you
off and yet when i was
so what so when i was just starting my
sentence then what did you just do you
just cut me off and yet when i started
sentence and now you're rolling your
eyes that's not rude you see what i mean
every time i start a sentence you cut it
off
i just listened to your entire statement
and when i responded and you cut me off
you're being quite rude and i think if
you re-watch this later you'll see the
energy you're bringing men don't bring
this energy that's the thing like women
get away with this stuff you're a pretty
girl that's why you get away with it
maybe honestly
i really like do you agree fully with
your statement yeah women don't talk
about men don't get it women get into
bars so many men's issues that we need
to bring up i agree and have higher
suicide rates they're working harder
jobs yes the pay gap
arguably does not exist do we agree on
this yeah i agree perfect but that does
not mean that feminism is a female
supremacy movement i think it is
feminism what's the definition what
definition do you give it the definition
well they they talk about equality but
they don't mean it so you mean it
because own definition
and define it for the rest of women
everywhere when there's women out there
that are being abused when there's women
out there that have a higher chance of
domestic violence and you're going to
stand for the majority
in leicester square where there's women
passing by that i'll probably in
domestic probe i probably don't have
you're thinking about buying okay cut me
off cut me off because i'm making a good
point cut me off i hope you guys really
good
i will keep going because i'm making a
good point that's why you don't want to
interrupt me yeah i hope you guys
honestly feel like you guys are
spreading a good message because all the
women out here aren't feeling you are
okay i honestly really feel like you
guys are spreading a terrible message
and i'm so sorry that you feel this way
because feminism is not a supremacy
movement it's in a movement for equality
because women out in the world are not
equal are not equal to men how so how
pick a country in the west how so in the
west in the uk in the uk what rights do
we not have why is it that if we look at
the oxford record of when women are
hired against men women are less likely
to be hired because they're more
expected to have babies and take
maternity leave
that's not necessarily true
women women women women women it's like
to be higher than men let's say i'm in
my early 20s i want to get a job they're
thinking oh she's going to have a job
and get she's going to get maternity
leave for a year i'm going to pay her
for a year but she's not working who's
less likely to get paid than a man how
can you say that when we have quotas
that are specifically for women quotas
they're they're
yeah yes i am how can you how how can
you can can you let me finish can you
let me finish my favor can you can you
no no i'm not there's hiring quotas
there's quotas that companies have where
they say we need to can again see
if you're cutting me off again yeah an
amount of females yes you need to have a
certain amount of females in certain
roles
why because there's not enough female
representation because they don't want
to do it it's not the same way there's
not enough representation of people of
color because they don't want to do it
because women don't want to have
positions of power no they don't you
know what i really wish you loved the
rest of your women
i really hope that when you you're
okay
shame shame shame insult guilt need to
be right
shame
i will okay five welcome welcome to
world star
i ask people their opinion on this topic
if they agree or disagree so it means
it's at the ex it's um it's at the
expense of men so it's not about
equality it's about being superior to
men exactly so i agree with you yeah so
we just ask people if they agree or they
disagree
so why because i i believe that there
are no differences and it's proven even
in sports now that females can run fast
jump higher swim from swim deeper etc
nevertheless
are there are hindrances on women that
biologically and naturally such as you
know giving birth and having maternity
leave and luckily now we have paternity
leave however
uh
you know
women tend off to accept you know
not not to go all the way to the top
therefore that's why we have
the majority of the ceos and the top
companies and and limited companies and
firms are male fortunate or
unfortunately well you know why don't
you think we ever talk about men's
rights like paternity fraud
exactly men men deserve to
to
be
to people to sympathize with them
because they work hard and they work
hard and they expect to work even harder
whereas you know
they don't go shopping during the day
but they're supposed to to bring the
money for the female to go shopping
during the day and night you think
feminists only care about equality when
it doesn't benefit them so for example
we always hear about how women are in
power positions but they never talk
about how men do all the hard jobs
absolutely i mean
to be fair we have to say
you know to to
to discuss both arguments of the subject
matter and and and mention the fact that
not all female of course i'm not all all
men but to have equal rights it doesn't
have to be
um like parallel equal like you know
exactly men should be exactly as as as a
female
it's like it's like differences
opposites attract and and differences
sometimes are are are great you know you
can be tall i can be short you can be
white i can be
gray red but we can we can still be
partners and and colleagues and
uh cooperate rather than compete what
does equality look like to you equality
is there anything we need to fight for
in 2022. now it's 2023 hopefully soon
but and what's remaining of the 2022 i
think we should be fighting for what has
been mentioned more cooperation less
competition more understanding accepting
allowing however you know not forgetting
that we are all one at the end of the
day no difference of color race
uh geographical to tend to to to
remember where we come from in order to
to find
to to realize to think ahead to know
where we're going however the past is in
the past the future is we don't know
what's going to happen so we just need
to live the moment stay in balance yeah
i agree thank you for stopping
there's an inequality are you like some
gap is that what you're talking about
i feel like we're going to rule the
world to be honest
what society
that has stood that stood the testament
of time has ever been ruled by women
i've got no idea none probably
but not necessarily no no i agree with
you yeah it's interesting you know women
are more likely to wage war
wait
yeah
so women are more likely to start worse
examples
like when women are in power you can
just look it up well no but no but women
make better ceos especially in companies
when in power
huh women of power do better in business
situations because they're a little bit
more empathetic and copacetic and
they're able to manage excellent you
think more women
well you think more women would be part
of the one percent not necessarily
because we live in a patriarchal society
do you think it's because of the
patriarchy of course 100 okay why
there's nothing stopping me if i want to
be a ceo um no there is because you're
in a picture yeah historically it's
patriarchal society of course men are
men and they're like what does that have
to do with me today i was born like i
was born in 1996. oh my gosh
i
hate when men try to explain that i am
oppressed take your white knight ass for
your girlfriend okay respectfully and
you know you seem like a nice person
nothing personal but like take your
white knight ass and do that for your
girlfriend take that away from here if
your girlfriend wants to believe she's
oppressed and this girl didn't even
really seem like she felt oppressed but
like whoever whoever you're talking to
or whoever you're doing this for go take
that there because here or we have
winner mentality we have we can do it
mentality okay
yeah yeah no so i'm saying like if
anything i think it's easier to be a
woman and at most jobs like i would say
i've been given better treatment because
i'm a woman oh yeah in europe or in the
u.s both that's incorrect you're telling
me you're telling me that's incorrect
yes okay yes being a a man who's in the
u.s and has been in the industry for
over 20 years what and what and equality
i've been in engineering and in
advertising okay okay but women don't
want to be engineers actually they do
there's a whole thing to come yeah no no
they don't because they don't enroll to
be engineers in college if we wanted to
be engineers not a role they're actually
not nurtured to be in system and they're
not given the opportunity to be in stem
but then why do when you look at the
countries that have more opportunity to
do what we want to do
so like like scandinavian countries
versus like countries in the middle east
where women have less rights and it's
pretty equal like the pay graph it
increases it doesn't decrease so when
women have more choice the pay gap
increases so you can't actually say the
direct correlation between two right
correlation is not causation no i
understand that but i'm asking why is
that that's a good question i'm not a
researcher on that but i'm not saying
that you can directly tie the two
together right i would say women like
even just from anecdotal experience like
men are men are more likely to help you
when you're a woman i've never done that
yeah i never have not gone for a job and
not got it yeah anecdotally i'm saying
and if and if i'm looking at data that
supports it like that's how i'm inclined
to believe what i believe so i'm curious
so i'm saying like why do you believe
what you believe because research shows
and research from what i believe is
peer-to-peer evaluated especially the
good
okay what what research i'm just curious
oh there's plenty of research if you
look at anything from like which one
this insider new york times and new
yorker a lot of them support the fact
that women don't have as much
opportunity as men i'm not saying it's
right yeah but i do believe that women
should have the opportunity and there
are women who are discriminated look at
the pay gap right yeah but the pay gap
like like no two groups are going to be
paid the same but they should be that's
why this country
you've you've seen there's there's
certain countries that actually do have
this openness about what people's
salaries are right and when salaries are
not disclosed that's when you see a pay
gap well i'm saying like 60 of women
have never asked for a raise so how can
so how about but i'm saying how can we
complain about something when like we're
not asking for raises why are you not
asking that's a real question because
we're but we're yeah we're [ __ ] we're
scared do you not believe you're worth
it well
what do you mean do you believe you're
worth the what mentally
no i'm saying i'm saying women are more
agreeable so we're more likely to agree
we're mad so but i'm saying that's
biology that's not the society biology i
completely 100 percent disagree with
biology
i'd like to hear why you think it's
biology well i would just say like
biology why because throughout history
like men typically had to be more
aggressive biology i want to hear the
biological physiological explanation for
why you think that's the case i'm saying
when you take men and women at large
right and you and you measure their
personality traits like women are are
more agreeable than men and and i and
i'm saying so and the reason i think
that also is because if you look at
countries that are more free the pay gap
increases i think it's pretty easy like
when you look at things like
scandinavian countries again where
they're more egalitarian and like
countries in the middle east east where
they're less like that's pretty you
would agree like like saudi arabia where
women can't draw
i actually don't know if i agree with
that statement free is a very subjective
term if you ask saudi arabian women if
they're free a lot of them say they're
actually freer than those who are from
christian based
countries you're right right but so the
way i would say under the law
under the law
so like under the law if you look at law
or even if you look at the law for
islamic countries women have a lot of
power whether they exercise or not is a
whole different issue and whether
they're under a conservative so how
would you define free that that's a
great question that's why i'm asking you
no no no no no i'll tell i'm telling you
what i'm saying so like but you're not
defining it that's a problem
so the way the way i'm saying it is like
men and women that have equal
opportunity there's no law holding them
back so like for example in saudi arabia
a couple years ago women couldn't drive
i would say that's not free and when you
look at countries that go like drive
driving equates to freedom partially
yeah that's one freedom
voting that's another free like yeah
education yes education is true another
one but yeah again correlation is not
causation so i think you have to take
into account other factors that surround
it so driving i think is a great example
of that voting education great i think
that's perfectly great and i totally
agree with that yeah but i wouldn't use
driving as an example
what i wouldn't use driving were you
education would you use education
absolutely isn't driving
an education it's an issue to get
somewhere right but if there's no
transportation that's another forum okay
well i was saying like if if it was the
case that
continues yes it's okay like i'm curious
no no it's okay it's okay i'm saying
like if it was the case that we were
really so oppressed and held back and it
was the patriarchy like in the countries
where we had more freedom we would do
better and we don't like i think women
pick different things like women like
people men like objects i'm not sure if
i agreed that statement but i know where
you're going with that argument like
okay i'm one of ten i have ten siblings
i'm one of ten five boys five girls i
was always told i could do whatever i
want my brothers are all engineers i'd
rather die than be an engineer props to
you
i'm not doing that anymore it doesn't
mean i
do it anymore right yeah i mean i'm not
eating so i'm like and even if we look
at like the hard jobs
industry yeah i get
um i i think even if we look at like the
hard jobs right what do you just what do
you define a part like bricklaying
plumbers electricians you know i think
my job's hard physically
yeah is that where you're physically
demanding yeah i'm sorry a bricklayer
that's harder than a nanny like just
like it's not at all my job is better if
you talk about physically demanding yes
there's certain
position
yeah i'd say jobs that would
probably be easier
gender but gender is also something that
i think you need to define as well to
define gender yeah oh if you're born a
man if you're born a woman i mean how do
you define born as a man
[Music]
the the the chromosomes like xxx1 people
who are born to three chromosomes or one
missing chromosome how do you find them
um i don't know how i would just find
the function because you know there's
more people who are born with an extra
chromosome people who are redheads so
they exist more than you do so how would
you define them they're not men or
female i don't know i don't know how i
define that though and that's why i
asked the gender question okay
what do you mean i mean i would just say
like you said gender but when i'm
talking about the rule i'm not talking
about the exception so but i'm saying
like a lot of times
i'm not trying to be rude you keep
interrupting me when i'm trying to talk
like your argument makes sense that's
why i'm interrupting you yeah i know but
like again that's rude like like like
this is supposed to be a polite
conversation
no i i it's not polite when you keep for
interrupting me i thought this is a
place of uh pre-discussion and
apparently we have free rules yeah i
mean is this equal i mean if you're are
you just more agreeable
i i am that's why i'm nicely telling you
and i'm not interrupting you
you should fight for what you want right
yeah yeah we shouldn't that's your point
then
you're talking about exceptions right a
lot of times a lot of yeah because the
majority of people are born with two
chromosomes not three
so and that's what i'm saying i'm
talking about the rule i'm not talking
about the exception there's no rule
though that's a problem i think you need
to use right now do you do you think
that do you think that gender doesn't
exist i agree that gender does not exist
so how would you define a man and a
woman i don't define a man and a woman
so could i be a man you could if you'd
like to be yes how
so depends on how you define a man
i don't believe in the binary system
okay explain more
so like once again as we went over this
once before okay two percent population
which is more than people who are
redhead okay i'm talking about for me
if you allow me to and not interrupt
okay go ahead there's more people that
are born with an extra chromosome who
are not men or female who not who have
not only one genitalia but two okay how
people describe a man or a woman depends
on what side they live in some
describe it as a gentilia others believe
it's on hormones on hormonal and what
you actually which one is greater
testosterone or whether it's estrogen if
you look at the lipid system right now
olympics now defines it as having a
certain level of testosterone or
estrogen not on genitalia there's women
who have been dis excluded from female
competitions because they have a higher
level of testosterone
but they were born with female parts are
they female or male they're including
because they're female so if lebron
james went on estrogen for two years
they would be included
so he could compete in the women's
division well according to the division
when people govern that
sport
they probably would be excluded would
you agree with that
i'm not the one who's an expert on that
i leave that to experts who are medical
physicians based on like common sense
i'm not an expert in physiology or
biology i'm not a doctor wouldn't you
leave it to experts no i mean i play i
play them i need to leave a climate
change i don't have an opinion on
climate change you don't yeah do you
believe it happens or not
would you leave that to the expert fund
my point is leave it to the experts i
don't know i think there's some
conclusions you can just draw like what
is a man and what is it
so i leave do you do you lebron james
i'm not the i'm not i'm not the
governing body nor the experts on that
so i would leave it on those who
actually have that expertise okay okay
thank you for stopping i appreciate it
i like how the girls said good i'm
telling you we don't want to liberals
you're here out of the horse's
[Music]
all right agree or disagree with the
sign no i disagree i can't lie to you
why because i'm not gonna lie to you
female right now because of whatever
you're actually taking right now they
seem like they're bad immense and that's
not true it has to be equal because they
give them a lot of power which is like
as a male you go ask a female even if
you went like literally in prison
they're going to believe her not you
because if she said that you're
harassing us straight they're going to
say yeah you do and you might want to go
in jail for it and that's not true you
should have have to like give us a mail
a bit like has to be equal that's all i
can say so i think we agree yeah you
agree
yeah i agree with you women women women
women it's not about equality women
think they're better than that now by
females thinking like bad and male 1
that's not good i'm i'm confused i'm
confused right now g i know it's not
good so i agree you agree on that yeah
that's why it's a supremacy movement
because women want to women want
equality at the exp at the cost of men
they want to be above that let's be
honest though yeah
yeah yeah in real life right now do you
think who's got the most power in the
women women women yeah and i don't like
that we make 70 to 80 of consumer buying
decisions and a bunch of sips
tell us what we want to hear all the
time but i don't like that i'm not happy
with that i i'm not either like why
don't we have why don't we have dna
testing
these
these i was telling these
but anyways i don't know but i think
they have to change this that's all i
can say who is
[Music]
tell me why tell me why
[Music]
is the best person alive he's basically
god we praise him every night
and basically
and you take all the
feminism is a female supremacy movement
agree or disagree completely disagree
tell me why well first of all i think
like feminism as a movement has become
so what i actually liked about this
interview was that she was very
open-minded and what i don't enjoy is
coming into a conversation and
just feeling like like talking to
someone is
you know there's no point like it's
completely lost and what i liked about
her is that even though we disagreed we
still could have a productive
conversation and you know maybe even
find a little middle ground more of a
movement for white women like it doesn't
really like include women of color
and things like that but i think like
saying it's a female supremacy movement
i just don't like i just don't think
that's true um you don't think that
women only complain about double
standards when they don't benefit them
so for example we always talk about how
women aren't in the one percent of like
income but we don't talk about how women
don't do any of the hard jobs what's a
hard job bricklaying plumbing
electricity oil rig but would
are people allowing women to do their
jobs yeah but it's also you have to take
into like consideration the genetic
differences between men and women when
it comes to jobs like that like hard
labor jobs like that um
so
right so so we're only talking about
equality when it doesn't benefit us so
like name okay what is a right that i
don't have in 2022 what's holding me
back as a woman abortion it's legal up
to six months in the uk around the world
it's time okay so why but even with that
right men don't have the right to not be
fathers so that's a right that women
have that men don't but a lot of men
aren't fathers
is that your opinion on men yeah that
the majority aren't fathers the majority
i don't think the majority want to take
the responsibility of being a father and
if they are a good father they're
praised more than they should be when it
really is just like no one no woman gets
praised for being a mother on mother's
day mother there's mother's day there's
father's day but even on father's day
like women single mothers will say their
their mother like they'll celebrate
themselves on father's day but you don't
really see fathers doing that on
mother's day because they're not being
fathers
like you see but see even with you right
like i sense a slight disdain for men
because you
yeah and that's you're kind of proving
my point right because when i talk to
girls with this mindset like it's they
want to be better than men or they think
that women are better than that because
i do think
i i think in a sense yeah actually i do
think that women are better so yeah so
so you kind of agree with the side maybe
yeah now i'm like changing my mind yeah
because like most of the time i think
the way like like me reading the sign at
first glance like it makes it seem like
it's a negative it is
i don't think it's it's sexist i don't i
don't know i don't think it's sexist to
think you're better you know
i think the world is like already very
like sexist towards like women okay and
i think because of all the sexism that
has happened up till now
women want to
be better than men because i mean
honestly like women should take revenge
that that's my
how were we oppressed historically when
we didn't have to fight and worse
men have protected us throughout all of
history but who are they protecting us
from like when men say they're
protecting us from like whatever who are
they protecting us from evil people
usually it's other men
yes you're right you're right but even
like that's true right men do commit
more crimes and like i'll give you that
they're more disagreeable but the thing
is like
it's because women can't like i'm
honestly when i do street interviews i'm
not afraid of man i'm afraid of women
i'm afraid of getting punched in the
face by a woman that's also because
you're holding up this well i but but
i'm saying if i hold a sign that most
men disagree with they don't treat me
like that because sometimes sometimes
i'll hold up signs like the opposite
just to get people talking but it's only
it's only women that treat me like that
i mean i think that's a very specific
situation i would say in general like
you know walking in the streets i'm
usually scared to leave my apartment
because of men of how like other men
make me feel and i think like like the
way
like the thing is like even when it
comes to things like rejection and
things like on a night out like if i'm
kind of scared to reject a man in fear
of him hurting me like physically or
like physically hurting me men don't
have to worry about them if they get
rejected it's just like embarrassing for
them they don't have to fear for their
lives so there's two things the first
part you talked about sorry you talked
about walking home alone at night why
are you entitled to security in a
dangerous city so men can't walk home
alone at night they could they could get
mugged men are more likely to be victims
of a violent crime than women i've
literally been like
i've literally been like almost punched
like walking home late at home at night
unprovoked so it's like right because i
don't think you can just
like i don't think you can compare like
specific like situations from each other
and like
i would say like as a whole women are
it's just more scary for women to like
leave their homes and like not expect
something bad to happen but i'm saying
why when men are more likely to be
victims of a violent crime like i think
i think can i can i can i can i can i
can i finish can i can i other men
you know what i mean like women not
amber heard look at look at what
happened okay yeah that's one situation
out of like so in most domestic abu
abusive relationships the both people
are hitting each other so it's not it's
not one-sided like both both parties are
hitting each other and men are more
likely to be victims of one-sided abuse
where the woman's hitting the man and
he's not hitting back
because men face consequences in society
women don't men get three times the
amount of sentencing for the same crime
as women we get away with [ __ ] i mean
even did you did you hear about that um
car accident that car accident can i can
i can i can i can i finish i don't i can
i can have like the same purpose white
women to get away with like the same
[ __ ] even in l.a that girl wasn't white
the girl in um la that just caused that
car crash she was like hispanic or
something and she she killed she killed
she she
let me let me let me finish she killed
six people and she walked that one
probably white passing one two that's
like one situation out of many
situations that white women have gotten
away with like it's
again like feminism and like the
privilege that women have it's not the
same like white women privilege like
they have more privilege and they
benefit more from certain things that
women of color don't do you believe in
pretty privilege to an extent yes who's
more privileged an average white girl or
like willow smith an average white girl
for sure you think more than willow
smith
100
she's born into a one percent family
if if willow smith was not willow smith
if she was just a regular girl no but
she's she's not yeah but i'm saying so
we're not like so let's not let's not
talk about if let's talk about what is
but that's you can't compare you can't
compare yourself to willow smith but if
you compare like you to me like you do
have more privilege than i do or my
friend does like really i don't think so
i think you guys i would say i would say
you guys are both prettier than me you
probably have pretty like i think you're
more pretty privileged but like pretty
privileged aside like and a lot of
pretty privilege like people look at
things like skin color like race like
i'm darker skinned like i'm not gonna
benefit the same way you do really i
don't care about that stuff like it's
right but a lot of people do we're
conditioned to like believe
who which people everyone society like
racism has happened for so many years
colorism has happened for so many years
it's not going to go away overnight do
you feel like everyone here is
you get more privilege like i get more
privilege than the way they look at us
look at us how like how are they looking
because you were saying that everyone's
everyone looks at you differently based
on like skin color a lot of people do
yeah a lot of people will look at me and
you differently like we don't get the
same privilege
how do you know it's not just you like
your personality maybe they just don't
like you
it's definitely not just that i can tell
you that for sure
i mean maybe but i'm sorry so but going
back to it like the point is like women
get away with stuff like all the time in
society and no one cares men get a lot
get away with a lot of stuff too like
not necessarily men go to men go to jail
all the time for crimes they didn't
commit a girl could say that someone
graped him and get him kicked out of
school like like in the u.s there is a
case and i'm just giving you an example
and it doesn't mean it's the only
example i'm just giving you one of many
right so there was a case where a woman
said that a dude assaulted her yeah and
there's video evidence of her bringing
him back to the dorm pulling hit like
like so clearly hitting on him he gets
kicked out of school that stuff doesn't
happen to women it only happens to matt
and men really aren't taken seriously
when they're victims of a crime i can
agree with like men do
men can't speak up as much because of
you know
this whole concept about men have to be
masculine they have to be brave
so like to an extent i like agree that
men don't come out or aren't you know
confident enough to speak out about the
issues they face
but
i don't i wouldn't say that women get
away with more
even if they get three times the same
sentencing for the same men get three
times the same sentencing for the same
crime i don't know much about like i i
would have to like read more
so if if that was true if that was true
would you would that change your opinion
a little bit maybe a little bit it makes
you like think a little bit you know
yeah it definitely makes you think and
even with abortion like
women are incentivized to trap men so
like the nba issues statements say it's
not flush your condoms
right
so because
no they can't no no they can't they can
but like what happened to drake
why is he putting hot sauce in it and
you get wasn't true
he posted a bottle of hot sauce right
just you just wear condoms i guess i'm
saying it was true that many women were
stealing them because why would the nba
issue statements every year saying flush
yeah like that's the number one way nba
players go broke well then i think then
men should like choose to wear a condom
if they don't want to get a woman
pregnant no but they they can and then
the girl can still steal the condom
that's legal so again women like get
away with [ __ ] okay i've talked to
people all the time on the street right
every day i have i've met so many men to
come up to me and tell me stories of how
a girl traps them
that's wild
and yeah i know i'm not trying to i
don't know
and i'm not saying it's all girls but
i'm saying legally like girls are paid
out for bad decisions if you're a single
mom you get money right if you like
every time we make a decision there's a
fail safe so for example for example
like if i get pregnant i can get an
abortion if a man gets a girl pregnant
he has no way out he can't he can't sign
off his rights and say i don't want to
pay child support for 18 years where
women we could say i don't want to be a
mother i can i can get an abortion i can
give the kid up for adoption it's like
all in our hands because we're the ones
carrying the child well what's harder
carrying a kid or raising it like dogs
dogs carry kids i think we give
ourselves a little too much credit
carrying and raising and women do both
of that no men do too
men do too
not to the same extent that women do
that's another thing the reason the
reason it's not equal is because men
don't win in court women women get
custody 80 of the time so it's like but
feminists don't care about this there's
men that spend like 20 thousands of
dollars trying to go to court and they
go broke they lose their life savings
trying to get their kids and there's
nothing they can do i mean in those
instances like see that's a bit more
complex to talk about because i don't
know like no it's okay i don't expect
people it's not the common narrative no
but it's but it's also like you know
that depends from situation to situation
like what's whatever that man's
background is versus the woman like
whatever their history was like whatever
their relationship was if if there was
like infidelity involved like all these
things play factor so it's like it
really depends from situation to
situation
do you think you think men have should
have the same uh chance of you know
being a father and like being like being
able to raise their kids and having
custody over their children would you
support a financial abortion so men can
say like let's say i get pregnant
tomorrow right and the dude that knocked
me up says i don't want anything to do
with that kids i i don't want to pay
child support can sign off my rights is
the same way i get to not be a mother
would you support that if a if a man
said yeah he could sign off his rights
and not pay child support like the same
way if if i want to get an abortion the
men have no say it's my body my choice
so would you say it should be equal
no because they're not the ones carrying
the child
like they're not yeah
but this like further proves my point
like we want the we want freedom without
the responsibility so we want to be paid
out for bad decisions i don't i don't
think that's the case i think it's just
i think you can't you can't compare
like a ma what a man goes through to
what a woman goes to genetically we are
different like we we do
like our anatomy is different like
genetically we're different like we like
we're just made differently so it's like
we're never going to be equal in a sense
but i don't think like
i don't i don't think i should be equal
under the law
like you know i understand like men and
women are different but under the law
shouldn't we be equal
i think so
yeah we're all humans like under
but yeah then again when it comes to
stuff like abortion and like having kids
it's just a little bit more tricky i'd
say but you don't so you don't
if you want it to be equal under the law
you so you still would stand on no
financial abortion i don't know like if
if
yeah i mean if i get like knocked out by
a guy and he's like i don't want to pay
like
i don't want to you know i want i don't
want anything to do with this child i i
don't know if i'd want to have that
child if like my baby daddy's not ready
to like support us
and like you know what i mean like carry
that yeah but you you get the choice you
know that's the point but like feminists
want we want the freedom without the
responsibility i do understand what
you're saying like it does make me think
for sure and even even like if we're bad
with money there's there's women's
shelters there's not men's shelters you
know men are just homeless
right so it's kind of like we have i
think like women don't really know how
privileged we are in general
yeah
much to think about yeah no no i like
honestly you you've been a good sport a
lot of people come in very aggressive
and so i really appreciate you coming in
i appreciate this conversation it
definitely made me think
i think i'm definitely still pro with it
it's okay
i support women's rights but most
importantly i support women's wrongs so
that's how i'm gonna
[Music]
your question is feminism is a female
agreed to a supremacy movement 100 agree
the reason being if you look at the
history of supremacy movements in the
past they're usually created by a a
a supposition that there's a conspiracy
from a certain group of people who are
trying to oppress or harm others the
nazis did it with the jews the kkk did
it with the black people in the south
and the feminists do it to men via the
conspiracy of the patriarchy that they
claim is oppressing them but what
they're actually doing is that they're
taking away the natural rights of
certain men so you have a lot of men
nowadays suffering from the divorce
courts from the fact they can't display
their masculinity or that they'll be
called a misogynist if they disagree
with their girlfriend going outside to
the nightclub alone you can clearly see
that there is there is you know just a
general hatred
of men from that group of people and
it's not all women doing it it is this
you know subset of feminists who think
that men have
this conspiracy that they're out to get
them which is not true because if you
see in the west the men here are quite
you know very passive you know they're
the typical nice guy they don't want to
hurt women you know they treat him in a
very nice way compared to other
countries yet still they say that men
are the oppressors and really it's not
based on any reality it's just some
conjured up conspiracy theory i agree
i've had two girls today tell me they
think they're better than men women are
better than men and women are equal so
that that is basically another sign of
female supremacy we're all equal
uh whether you believe in a god or
whether you're secular you're atheist we
all have equal rights and that's how it
should remain you know i actually think
men are unequal
yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't think we're
equal i think women have more rights
without the responsibility yeah that's
true if you look in the divorce courts
for example men 90 percent of the time
lose the case they have to pay for the
child that they hardly ever see
men in in relationships have have a real
bad time at the moment because
you know
if they if they for example fled with
another girl then that girl would go
ballistic
you know and that relationship would end
but if his girl does it and he has he
has a problem with it then he's a toxic
masculine
misogynist
which
clearly there's a double standard there
yeah yeah i agree i couldn't have said
it better myself you you said you you
watched the channel you found i watch a
channel i like it because it's uh i
don't wanna i was gonna mention some
other channels but i won't because it's
kind of like i'm sounding like i'm
generating beef but it's better than a
lot of the other red pill channels
because they focus on trashy subjects
where what you focus on is a pure
intellectual level dissecting
the the
i would say the issues that men and
women have unfortunately have today in
the west in terms of intersexual
dynamics which a lot of people
are either ignoring or getting it
completely wrong well thank you so much
i appreciate it